[Music]
good day everyone you'll have to excuse
my vocal performance in this one not
only did i finish up a voiceover for a
different video today but i also just
got done screaming on stream so yeah my
voice is uh kind of
hoarse anyway we got a new trailer or
rather another teaser for breath while
two or wait it's not called breath wall
2 anymore now is it the legend of zelda
tears of the kingdom a title which as
far as i'm aware nobody guessed
correctly the following will be a short
analysis and first impressions of what
we just saw which wasn't much yet again
but hey again it's nice to see the game
show up again so let's get right into it
the teaser opens up with a set of wall
decorations or some sort of mural all
depicting various characters and
monsters the first character is very
enigmatic it kinda looks like it's
wearing a mask with owl-like features
especially the eyes though it could also
be a stylized depiction of his actual
face and dare i say if this ends up
being a zonai or some other ancient
tribe it could be that they are a
completely different species to humans
these two protrusions at the side of the
head definitely hint as such again if it
ends up not being a mask the wave
pattern at the side of the body seems to
suggest really really long hair though
again it could also just be some sort of
decoration of sorts it could be that
this is depicting ganondorf who does
have really long hair but i'm not too
sure about that one to me it looks more
like some sort of elder or maybe even
the head of this mystery tribe i'll be
sure to analyze this further in the
future the next mural seems to depict
some sort of battle a battle between the
typical monsters we know like moblins
and the goblins and humanoid characters
carrying swords and shields we also see
two figures who seem to have fallen on
the battlefield one of the soldiers all
the way on the side and one here in the
middle this one could be some sort of
civilian seeing as they are dressed
differently than the other characters
and they don't carry a sword or shield
it looks to be some sort of war against
one of the first iterations of calamity
ganon moblins and pokolins are ganon
soldier of choice and these red lines
seem to depict malice whatever this
battle is it seems to have taken place a
long long time ago because it doesn't
really match with the tapestry from 10
000 years ago we don't see any shika
monks or shika tech and these warriors
also don't really seem like hylian
soldiers to me the next screen shows a
bit more of the character we covered at
the beginning we can see them standing
on some sort of floating altar and if
you look very closely you can see what
looks like mountain tops at the bottom
this could suggest that this altar is
floating high above hyrule maybe it's
even a stylistic depiction of one of the
islands so it does look more like it's
man-made as the camera pans upward we
can see that the character is surrounded
by seven circles or seven orbs it's
possible that these are representations
of the seven sages which if true could
mean that they play some sort of role
but it could also be something different
something new we also see what looks to
be stylized clouds on the side
confirming that this platform is indeed
high in the sky somewhere next we cut to
a female figure who seems to be either
dead falling down or maybe even being
sacrificed who knows i think i'm not
alone in concluding that this might be
an incarnation of zelda either a very
ancient version of her or this mural is
predicting a future event namely the
event we saw in the other teaser where
we see zelda falling down though i do
have to say her hair seems a lot longer
so it may again be something that
transpired a long time ago it then cuts
to a different figure i don't really
know what to make of this character he
looks to have some sort of symbol on his
forehead which is a shika thing but it's
too early to draw conclusions like that
their arm also looks a bit weird almost
mechanical in some way though this could
again just be stylistic of course if i
had to guess it could be the ancient
hero you know the one who many have
theorized about basically one of link's
predecessors and possibly the previous
owner of these clothes link is seen
wearing we then see a door depicting two
dragons link then opens the door and
makes a run for it and jumps off the
island and going into a dive just like
how we saw in the patents though you
might notice that this shot and this one
don't actually take place in the same
location when the camera snaps to the
front view the door is nowhere to be
seen and even the floor is different we
once again see the bracelet on link's
arm but this time we also see something
dangling on his hips which i'm not sure
but they kinda look like vials
containing a green substance either this
is some sort of story related object as
zelda games tend to have or it could
also be an indicator related to link's
new powers one that depletes the more
you use them kinda like the magic meter
this would mean that as opposed to the
sheikah slate which you can use
infinitely these new powers have limited
use
right before link jumps we also get a
good view of some of the sky islands we
see the familiar ones with the yellow
grass and yellow trees but we also see
what looks to be snow meaning some of
the islands have a different climate
than others which is pretty cool we also
see a massive grey building in a
distance and those who've scrutinized
the previous teaser may have noticed
that it looks eerily similar to this one
so it's either the same structure or
there's many like it across the sky as
link descends we briefly see the bottom
of one of the islands up close a sort of
upside down peak which looks to be
man-made and far below we can see the
surface of hyrule coming into view the
next clip is very exciting as we see one
of link's new powers in action more
specifically the rewind mechanic which i
made a whole video about it shows the
size of the objects link is able to
rewind which in this case is pretty big
it also shows that as expected you still
have control over link and you can
interact with these objects while
they're moving backwards in this case
holding on to it while it ascends we
then see a shot of link climbing nothing
special there god can you imagine if we
said that six years ago we have
definitely been spoiled we then cut to a
sequence which has quite a lot of stuff
to cover first of all we see a couple of
islands at a much lower altitude in full
view of hyrule's surface so not all of
them are like way way up there i mean
some of them are even lower than death
mountain speaking of death mountain that
is not lava oh no that is definitely
malice like damn we also see that hyrule
castle didn't actually go up into the
sky it remains floating in place
surrounded by malice i can also make out
some sort of a shape right here which
definitely wasn't there in the original
and i think i already know what this is
as we'll see something similar in just a
second then we see
well this thing i don't even know what
to call it like a paraglider or
something a giant hoverboard i have no
idea but it's cool and it seems to be a
new mode of transport up here we see a
drawing on the top of one of the
mountains a seemingly glowing depiction
of a dragon of sorts at least that's
what i think it is i'm not 100 sure but
it seems like this is the same thing we
just saw in the distance that shape i
was talking about lastly if you look
close to the bottom of the screen you'll
see what looks like a green spiral it's
obviously far away but it looks quite
similar to the one from the very first
breath to wild teaser which also depicts
green energy coiling upwards could this
perhaps be one of the pedestals i talked
about in previous videos the ones link
potentially uses to travel up into the
sky using his new abilities be sure to
let me know thus we end up at the title
screen and after that the release date
neither of which i have anything to say
about right now i don't think my voice
can take much more guys i'm sorry anyway
that is all for now look forward to more
videos about this game in the near
future we are just getting started this
is dawn signing off and have a good one
[Music]
you